[Music]
when it comes to life there are certain
things that only kids will understand
and that's just fine stay tuned to see
why we would all be better off if kids
ran the world are you new around here
don't forget to subscribe to the things
for more great videos like this now unto
20 things that only kids will understand
school lunch everyone knows that school
lunches aren't always the best so the
best feeling in the world was when your
mom would show up to school with
McDonald's or some other fast-food treat
everyone at the lunch table would be
instantly jealous and you felt like the
queen or king of the world only kids can
really understand how good it feels to
be eating warm delicious french fries
while everyone else is eating the same
old things that they eat every day cause
having your mom at school is pretty cool
and ty you're a teenager
so it's a win-win really pizza sticks
speaking of school lunch every kid knows
what the best day in the cafeteria is
it's Pizza stick day you know the ones
that pull apart and come with marinara
and dipping sauce it's making our mouths
water just thinking about it lunch line
is always super long on days that pizza
sticks are being served because everyone
knows just how delicious those little
sticks are and they are so good that a
lot of kids actually go back for seconds
it's the one school lunch that beats out
all of the others making a mess by the
time you're an adult messes start to
really get on your nerves for one you're
the one that has to clean everything up
as a kid you still understand the beauty
of things being a bit messy from time to
time think back to some of the most fun
that you ever had as a kid you were
probably playing in the dirt or making
mud pies when you were young the best
part of baking anything with your
parents was the mess that you got to
make if anyone says that they don't like
making messes then you know for a fact
that that person is probably an adult
having fun alone sometimes being alone
can be quite boring but one thing that
all kids know is how to have fun alone
why do they all have this skill because
they have to sometimes when they go
places with their moms they are the only
kid around so if they want to entertain
themselves they have to figure out how
to do it on their own also kids have an
insane imagination which makes it easier
for them to have so much fun with very
little they have so much fun by
themselves it's ridiculous having no
shame what is shame ask a kid and they
will have no idea today I'm
whatever decisions they make are the
right ones kids say the rudest most
straightforward things and don't have an
ounce of remorse if they hurt someone's
feelings or not they are absolutely
shameless they will run around in their
underwear and go to the grocery store
with no pants on if you let them why
because they don't care they are living
their best lives and could care less
what other people think about them we
could all take a page out of their book
maybe a little less shame is what
everyone needs dressing up sometimes you
just need to dress up like a superhero
and every kid knows that why wait for
Halloween when you can be a fairy
princess any day kids don't care what
day it is or what occasion it is they
are going to wear what they want to wear
ever seen a kid at a park in a full-on
fluffy dress
they probably woke up that morning and
decided they wanted to look fancy if a
kid has a parent that is willing to let
them pick out their own clothes then
there is no end to what they will come
up with extreme manipulation say what
you want but one thing that all kids
know for sure is how to manipulate
adults they get what they want by any
means necessary
and it's not even hard as a kid all you
have to do is bat your eyes at your
parents and then voila you get what you
want it's like a superpower that all
kids have for parents that kids are
their kryptonite's one look into their
big eyes and parents can't say no kids
know this all too well and they use it
to their advantage honestly this is a
super smart tactic and we wish we could
still use it
holiday greatness the holidays are
amazing but for some reason the older
you get the harder it is to be excited
about them that's why kids are the only
ones who really understand just how
amazing holidays really are as you get
older you find it harder and harder to
see all of the holiday magic but kids
don't have the stress of work and school
getting in the way of their holiday fun
no one knows pure joy and happiness
quite like kids that's why they are the
ones that get to do all the fun holiday
things like sit on Santa's lap and bake
cookies for Santa and his reindeer naps
can happen anywhere adults are forced to
go without naps they have to go to work
and make it through the whole day
without falling asleep for kids that is
not the case kids understand that a map
can and will happen anywhere whenever
they are tired they aren't afraid to
just lay down and nap until they are
ready to get up again
haven't you seen kids napping in some of
the weirdest places it's because they
truly don't care where ever they are
when they are tired is the perfect place
for a nap we wish we could be like that
Disneyworld is everything no one
understands the magic of Disney like a
kid
remember when you were little and you
saw that magical place for the first
time you probably couldn't believe your
eyes
you were so overcome with excitement but
it was insane with the older that you
get the less magical Disney becomes the
long lines and expensive tickets become
more important than how much fun the
park is that's why kids are the only
ones who truly can have fun at Disney
World it would actually make more sense
of Disney World for open only to kids
and there were no adults allowed their
needs
the older you get the harder it is to
know exactly what you need light begins
to get stressful and we lose sight of
what's most important for us but as a
kid you know exactly what you need and
when you need it when kids are hungry
they cry until they get the food that
they need when they need to run around
and play for a little bit they throw a
tantrum until they are allowed to go out
and play kids know what they need and
they aren't afraid to do what they have
to do to get it whether it be food a nap
or playtime they are going to let you
know when they need something there once
if adults are bad at knowing what they
need they are even worse at figuring out
what they want from relationships two
jobs the older that you get the harder
than it is to know exactly what you want
at any one moment but for kids
everything is very simple what they want
is black and white when they are hungry
they want food when they are bored they
want to play when they are scared they
want their parents there is no
in-between or gray area kids are direct
and they don't play around don't you
wish that adults could be more like that
the horrors of liquid medicine what was
one of the worst parts of getting sick
as a kid sure the aches and fever were
horrible but they did not compare to the
horror that was the taste of liquid
medicine having to gulp that down was
cruel and unusual punishment adults have
forgotten how horrible the medicine
tastes the older you get the more you
take pills instead of liquid medicine so
it's easy to forget how horrible the
liquid tasted but as a kid you know
exactly how horrible the stuff in those
bottles is the beauty in life the older
that you get in life the more stressful
things become it gets harder and harder
to see the joy in the small things in
life that is not the case with kids they
haven't yet felt the hardships of life
so for them everything is still nice and
beautiful no one understands just how
much beauty there is in ordinary things
more than children that's where the same
childlike Wonder comes from it
means that you are able to look at
things and enjoy them like a child what
a great way to view life pure love love
is hard most adults know this it's hard
to stay in love with people but for kids
love is easy they know exactly what love
is and how to get it from the very first
moment they are alive they have an
unwavering love for their parents rarely
do adults ever recreate the same pure
love that kids come into the world with
if all the adults in the world
understood pure love the way that kids
do then the world would probably be a
much better place with a lot fewer
issues don't you think maybe we need to
all have kids to this town and teach us
some lessons making people smile a lot
of times adults are very involved in
whatever they are doing rarely do they
ever look outside of themselves to see
what is going on with other people but
kids love to make people laugh and only
they understand how to make almost
anyone smile at any time all the kid has
to do is look at you in a certain way
and you will almost undoubtedly smile
back that's the beauty of kids they know
what's important in life and they know
how to make you remember what's
important as well if you haven't smiled
in a while hang out with a kid weakness
is okay one thing that kids definitely
understand that adults do not is that
showing weakness is completely okay
adults are afraid to show weakness
because they think that other people
will judge them if a kid is sad or hurt
they will show it no matter what they do
not care at all they understand the only
way to fix a problem is to let people
know would upset them if adults
understood this a lot of conflicts would
be solved more quickly wars could
probably even be stopped before they
started maybe we should just let kids
rule the world sharing is the worst
you're a kid and you're playing with
your favorite toy one of your mom's
friends comes over with their kids and
all of a sudden you're expected to let
her kid play with your toy wasn't that
the worst only kids understand how truly
annoying it is to have to share things
when you just want to keep them for
yourself
why is sharing necessary anyway why
can't everyone just get their own toys
then no one would ever have to share and
we could all be happy if kids were in
control then that would probably be the
case asking both parents kids understand
that getting what you want is a very
delicate practice which is why all kids
know that when one parent says no you
have to go to the other one to try to
get a yes out of them it's the basic
wall of kids science 101
kid has done it and kids will continue
to do it for years to come the only
catch is that when doing this you have
to make sure that you don't get caught
the other parent can never find out that
you asked their spouse the kids know
this and are able to pull it off
flawlessly and that's it for 20 things
that only kids will understand do you
have more things to add to this list let
us know in the comments thanks for
watching
[Music]